hello and welcome to our session
um starting in just a second here
setting up our live stream for our
LinkedIn live audience okay thank you so
much for your patience
let's get started
okay and welcome we are taking a look at
the post graduate program in digital
transformation this is a career
information session that is written by
simply learn we're the delivery partner
with Purdue University for this program
and uh
covered the agenda we'll be talking
about
digital transformation as a field and as
a career opportunity
um we'll also talk about what this
particular program offers and how it
works to get your job ready
I'll be sharing a demonstration of our
learning environment by one of our
senior instructors and
we'll talk about enrollment steps and
I'll take your questions
let's begin with careers in digital
transformation the digital
transformation
is the process that is basically
changing everything in our lives and
it's happened
in a
much more accelerated fashion since the
pandemic
I was
listening to a webinar from
a venture capital firm and one of their
Executives said very soon after the
pandemic started if they had told us
that we would have to all work from home
I would have told management it would
take us six months 10 million dollars to
set that up
and when it happened it took us three
days with no budget
um so our world changed virtually
overnight but that was just the the
acceleration of a process that's been
going on for decades in terms of
enabling
transactions on the web enabling
transactions on mobile phones
since the smartphone appeared a couple
decades ago and started to be able to
have apps on your phones
suddenly
Our Lives became much more digitally
enabled
so
businesses need to be able to make use
of this technology they need to figure
out how to change their business models
to adapt to a digital world they need to
understand how to deal with customers
when they don't see the customers face
to face
they need to understand
how to handle Commerce when
it's all self-service through e-commerce
websites or e-commerce apps on phones
so all of this becomes an opportunity to
help
businesses manage navigate that
transition that transformation
so
as we show here on the slide Business
Leaders have to understand the value of
the data that they get out of the
operations that they change it's not
just a matter of
pardon me changing operational
procedures but understanding where all
that new data comes from and how it can
be used
further transform your business
program and product managers create
those business models they understand
new ways to access customers new ways to
reach markets they couldn't reach before
and solution Architects and Technical
leads have to be able to implement those
changes and create the new digital
systems that support the new transformed
processes so
it's a great opportunity across the
spectrum of types of business positions
and roles
and
you can look at how it impacts every
rear from the top of the corporate
structure all the way through
every functional aspect down to
the customer facing the
supplier facing
every aspect of
organization changes as every aspect of
the consumer and the
user
in the external World changes so
it's important to understand all of
those different
aspects wherever you are in your
organization
so this is a important field to know
about no matter what career area you're
in
now there are a specific set of skills
and tools and ways of thinking that
apply to digital transformation and help
you use that
process in your role so understanding
digital disruption
what all of this means
large scale for the greater world around
you but also on the smaller scale for
your organization and then coming up
with a strategy to
deal with and manage that disruption
on creating new business models around
digital technology
using agile framework to
guide your project management and your
transformation processes
design thinking so that you
create new processes that are aligned to
how your customers understand and do
their business and
so that they look at these new processes
as part of a natural
extremely comfortable way to interact
with you
um
understanding people leadership again in
the example I mentioned of everybody
having to work from home three days
later
it's led to
entirely different and new ways for
people to manage
used to be long ago a book that
advocated management by walking around
where a supervisor could find out a lot
about
what was going on in an organization
just by roaming the halls and listening
in on
conversations and checking in with
employees
don't don't get to walk around when all
of your employees are working remotely
so you have to find different ways of
interacting with them managing them
motivating them
keeping the performance up to par so uh
that's an important aspect of digital
transformation both digital marketing
yeah and may never meet your customer
Face to Face customer may never interact
with it human being from your
organization
um which is a very different way of
doing business from
years or decades or centuries passed so
you need to understand the tools for
contacting potential customers for
engaging them and for helping them
through the transaction even
done without the intervention of a human
being and finally you need to understand
how artificial intelligence and machine
learning work
and can be applied in these transform
processes and what opportunities they
open up for you
we spoke with one point a
founder of a fintech firm she explained
that the only reason that the firm can
exist is because of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
enabling the systems at that firm to
understand the credit worthiness of
consumers in order to be able to make
micro credit decisions on the spot
instantaneously when people are at a
transaction point so
without that process you'd never be able
to understand the credit risk that a
person is presenting to you if they've
phoned you from a cash till and said I
want to make this purchase for this
amount of money
um Can you spot me or loan me that
amount
if it was a human-based process still it
would be impossible to do but with
artificial intelligence machine Learning
Systems can look at different aspects
including aspects not usually associated
with credit and come up with an
instantaneous decision so these are ways
that all of these different skills and
tools apply
in the process of digital transformation
and making your organization into
something
new new environment
so I have a poll question for you
oops wrong place
let me launch this poll
and leave this open for a minute or so
all right
numbers are still changing we'll leave
it open for another few seconds
and
okay I'll close the poll
now click that enter button
and here we go
so about half of our respondents say
that this is some
you hear that you wouldn't find the
Practical exposure that you wouldn't get
the Practical experience you'd need to
be able to demonstrate your new set of
skills
um and then the next most common answer
is that you can't find a program that is
a comprehensive curriculum that kind of
covers all of the different skills that
we just spoke about so
we'll talk about these points
Purdue University professional
certificate and digital transformation
this program
is offered by Purdue University it has
modules and content
and participation from KPMG India and
it's delivered by simply learn on our
platform
it's a program six months duration five
to ten hours we usually say 10 to 15
hours to be safe because each week
you're going to attend live online
virtual classes that means you're going
to be interacting live with your
instructor
uh and your peers in the classroom
and you'll spend a total of eight hours
a week in these live classes those are
the only parts of the program that are
uh on a fixed schedule the
and they usually happen on weekends or
in some cases uh weekday evenings you
can pick the format that works best for
you
um everything else that you do in the
program you do on the online platform
the same platform you take your classes
on and you and schedule any of that work
you can do it at any time that you feel
is
appropriate to your schedule so you can
be up at three o'clock in the morning
and be working on your project or
watching in video or emailing your
instructor or communicating with your
peers on the community bulletin board or
contacting our 24x7
support team if you have a question
about how the platform works or about
the subject matter all of that's
available to you on your schedule
and it has a comprehensive curriculum
that we'll cover in a moment that
includes integrated case studies from
Harvard Business School
Hands-On projects things that you will
do on the platform and turn in that will
be evaluated including a final project
called the Capstone
what you get from the program are two
certificates one issued by
Purdue and simply learning together
and the other issued by KPMG India and
simply learned together
and both of these certified that you
have completed successfully the core
material of the program
you get to the Hands-On project Capstone
project which is
something that uh
collectively you put all that into your
portfolio and can demonstrate your work
and experience to your employer or a
potential future employer
um you have the ability to take master
classes and level up sessions with
instructors from Purdue and apmg staff
members
and you get a membership in the Alumni
Association Purdue University so that
you'll have access to networking on a
lifelong basis
Purdue University if you're not familiar
with it is one of the oldest uh
public universities in the United States
established 150 years ago
by the state of Indiana
and uh
nickname for the students of
Boilermakers because it was in
itially an industrial school that taught
people how to actually make
um
boilers ductwork
steam engines things of that nature so
it was uh
always has been a technical mechanical
orientation over the years of course
technology has evolved and included a
digital technology in Purdue University
is one of the top public universities in
the United States it's produced Nobel
Prize winners Pulitzer Prize winners
his recognized worldwide as
a prestigious institution of Higher
Learning so having that on your resume
is
definitely
uh
good Mark that will
track the tension for you
we're also partnered as I mentioned with
KPMG India and KPMG is one of the big
four consulting firms I think it's the
big three at this point
with the presence in over 140 countries
it uh offers in this
particular course
several of the classes
offers master classes that are available
to you in addition to the Core
Curriculum and it guides you through a
number of the case studies in helps you
with the Capstone project
so
this is a great opportunity to interact
and learn from people who are very tuned
into industry and working with
leading companies around the world so
we talk about eligibility and
prerequisites and at this point
pretty straightforward
the eligibility
includes
one of two criteria you need to have
either a bachelor's degree in any
um
field
or you need to have
excuse me you need to have a
five years of experience in Industries
here
one moment I'm just
handling something in the background
here
so you do not have to have a particular
background it is desirable if you have
a background in general business
management
or in strategy
um
pardon me
and
um
so the requirements are pretty basic
again
um you want to be
generally speaking uh college graduate
or the equivalent of work in the
workplace again not
particularly tied to a given field
so I'm going to launch another poll in a
moment here once I get it set up
all juice for this
we're going to ask how much experience
you have
so
we'll launch this poll
and this one's much simpler so we won't
give it as much time
this gives us an idea of
where you fall into the
categories we just talked about for
the prerequisites so
the numbers have stopped or almost
stopped changing please get your answer
again I'll close the poll in five
seconds
three
two one
and
so almost two-thirds of the audience
have more than five years of experience
and qualified basic on that criteria
alone
um
about a sixth of the audience or folks
who are still in school
if you're going to graduate by the time
you finish this program that is to say
if you are
less than six months away from
completing your bachelor's degree by the
time you start this program so that
you'll have your bachelor's degree by
the time you end this program uh you're
eligible to to join
um with everybody else in the in between
categories presumably
you have your degree and you're working
so
that means you're qualified for the
program as well so again if you have
questions you'll want to contact our
learning Consultants that ask us at
simply learn.net and I'll share that
email address with you in a bit
but move on
because at this point we want to talk
about how the program prepares you
and for that we have a segment that I
did with Bernadette Chambers who is one
of our senior instructors in digital
marketing and digital transformation
she'll be able to preview for you what
the learning environment looks like
kinds of things she covers in her
classes and uh
how she mentors her
learners
so let me
share that with you
we will
so I will transfer control to you
all righty
and you can take it away
so one of the really cool things
we have an opportunity to use Miro Miro
how many of you guys have uh
learned about or know about mural boards
let me know in the chat
I'm going to show you what that looks
like in a bit
cool so the way that we use those is a
lot of times we use it for our
um our segments where we are able to
collaborate with one another in real
time
we also help to describe
um some of the things that we're talking
about in digital transformation I'm
going to take you guys to see what it
looks like inside of the LMS so that you
can have sort of a preview of some of
the courses that you can be expected to
take and then I will show you an example
of an actual project that comes out of
design thinking one of the projects that
some of my live students had an
opportunity to submit and these
particular students
so this all within their corporation so
I think that that might be interesting
for you guys to see it
to my LMS real quick
there we go and then I'll go into simply
learning
and then I'll show my screen
it's thinking guys
perfect
all right if everyone could confirm
um that they can see my screen real
quick here in the chat
perfect
all right
so this is the program of digital
transmission I have graduated at least
four cool Parts which is basically I'm
responsible for the project from start
to finish this is the actual course
segments so you'll be learning digital
disruption and strategies for digital
transformation this is design thinking
which is your second class agile
transformation
marketing for the digital age and how
these classes kind of interweave with
one another is basically you learn the
premise the concept of digital
transformation why it exists what
companies failed to initiate digital
transformation which ultimately caused
their demise companies like Circuit City
companies like uh Kodak and things like
that then you go into the actual
approach so this is like a six step
seven step approach where you learn them
in detail then you have the agile
business transformation Market for
digital age and then how to lead teams
and there's a very important messaging
inside of how to lead teams into digital
transformation because again one of your
greatest challenges initiating this
program is going against the status quo
then of course there is the Capstone now
I'm just going to show you really
quickly an example of some of the
projects that my students have submitted
in the past they are absolutely stunning
to look at because the way that I
deliver courses is a little different
than some other instructors might
deliver however my aim is so that you
understand exactly how to apply the
concepts at every turn and at every
class so I'm just going to show you
really quickly
some of the projects that they were able
to do
for example let me do
design thinking this was my last cohort
let's see empathy Maps this is a good
one
so one of the projects that they were
assigned and turned in was empathy Maps
this one was a really good empathy map
where we actually dove in to the key
personas and some of the things that
they should anticipate when
understanding their empathy and having
empathy with their Persona so they were
able to identify certain Trends what
were the trends in their industry that
was feeding certain customer Behavior
then they started to dive into what
businesses actually do to respond to the
to the trends and then they were able to
build how they Journey throughout that
process in the empathy map they also
built what was called point of view
statements which basically expresses how
the needs of the potential customers
work this was a fascinating
um and this I believe this student he
actually emailed me to let me know that
he had moved into leadership in a role
with some of the things or he was
offered leadership I think he took
something else but he was offered
leadership by turning in this we also
use these mural boards to kind of
understand how we're going to approach
this and we use tools like smaply and
other tools to be able to draw out and
really understand and focus have you
guys heard of snaply let me know in the
chat if you have a snap link
if you hadn't that's okay because you
will hear about it you will hear about
it in this so snaply actually is the
mechanism that they use to really prompt
the questions of how they go through so
if like I said it's a very Hands-On and
robust process and these projects that
we are completing these projects that we
are doing it is all for the
instructor-led that these are the
instructor-led where I actually walk
them through so you guys get an
opportunity to leverage these tools and
what I really like about smaply is you
can actually share once you have crafted
the different portions of the journey
you can actually share that with your
teams and your teams can collaborate
with you on the parts that they like and
what they don't like same thing with
tools like Miro you have a team
collaboration where you can actually
share as you can see I'm already in the
cohort we have 40 users that is a team
that's actually sharing their thoughts
and things like that and how they map
out certain views and certain things
that they're doing so really really
robust program a lot of things that you
learn like I said is by Hands-On and you
don't learn that by just going through a
course where you're listening to videos
you learn that by experiences with your
other classes and your people in your
classes you learn it through networking
with some of those because a lot of
those folks that are in those classes
are already in leadership they are
already in leadership they're just
learning how to enhance and by the
surveying and the polling of this class
you guys are as well so just to let you
know that's just some of the the preview
of that some projects that we actually
do some of the tools that we actually do
to communicate with one another and so
on and so forth
and
that was
a bit of a run-through of the learning
environment and the how the course works
I wanted to show you that
um
the
program builds up your digital
transformation
skills in a step-by-step fashion the
organization the modules within the
program
intended to make it possible for you to
um
seed in each class and have the
foundation to succeed in the following
class and So within the learning
management system you can only unlock a
course if you've completed the
prerequisite so uh you can't start the
first digital disruption module until
you've completed the orientation session
so on um but it builds up from the
orientation session which just gives you
the ability to uh understand how the
system works how the scheduling works
where you'll find the different tools
for the program
and where you'll find the different
information videos course files
please study documents and that type of
thing and then you'll move into your
first real course which is digital
disruption and strategies for digital
transformation
gives you the basic overview and
Foundation then you move into design to
thinking which is a important skill in
terms of creating new systems under a
digital
transformation looking at how to put
together the new systems that support
your digitally enabled processes you'll
look at agile business transformation
the
way that manage the transformation
project process and the projects within
that then you'll look at digital
leadership and how to push
digital transformation initiatives
through an organization
and finally you'll get into the
transformation Capstone project again
with an instructor uh like Bernadette
who will Mentor you through that process
help you create the final project
Capstone
um
the electives
along the way you can take any or all of
these electives at your discretion based
on your time availability and your level
of commitment these are all included in
the course
at no additional charge so you can take
of course the master classes from Purdue
and KPMG you can also take digital
marketing marketing for the digital age
you can get basics for AWS cloud
you can get a basic introduction to Big
Data
what it means and tools used to manage
it you can get an introduction to
Internet of Things
and finally an introduction or overview
of artificial intelligence all of these
are available to you at your option
um some of the tools in the Frameworks
you'll learn
so Bernadette Dimension Miro athlete
one
those are particular
tools you'll learn what the framework
for digital disruption is and how to
innovate collaboratively
learn the technique of brainstorming and
how to use that to generate new ideas
and new ways of looking at processes and
thinking about them you look at the
rapid ideation framework that allows you
to quickly generate and evaluate new
ideas you'll look at uh and she showed
user Journey mapping
look at the Innovation framework that
shows how Innovation fits into a
corporate structure and operation you
look at the Affinity diagram which looks
at how
people interact with processes and
you'll look at prototyping and the tools
you would use to make of mock-ups of
your new systems to rapidly put those in
front of potential users and get
feedback so these are some of the
different types of Frameworks and tools
available that you'll be using in a
Hands-On fashion in the program you'll
be working on
Harvard Business School case studies
from real companies
uh and you'll close uh presented with
the problems that they were basically
solving you'll be challenged then to
solve those yourself
um though you'll be going through these
exercises and these are types of program
case studies that might be the Capstone
project for you for example
pick one for the Capstone and you do
that process and the Capstone takes you
three to four weeks you meet with your
instructor weekly to make sure you're
not going down any rabbit holes or dead
ends or not reaching any blockers or
resolve any doubts you might have and
then
once you complete that Capstone project
based on that real world business
challenge you have uh
piece of actual work to put in your
portfolio to show off
be your potential future employer or
your current employer to demonstrate
what your new skill set includes how
you've used it
no
Capstone project
follows this particular process in this
course
you pick an industry you identify your
potential disruption in that industry
um so these are capstones based on
problems you identify rather than the
case studies you go and then look at the
market opportunities
um disrupt this industry How would
doing things differently with digital
capabilities allow you to
um
cut costs below what current people are
in the market are doing or find new
markets that aren't being addressed or
find other competitive advantages or
other opportunities you've developed
mock-up product that will address these
new opportunities out in that market
um use design thinking in order to come
up with what that product will look like
and how it will work and then you create
your business model
to show what that scale of that
opportunity is and
how profitable profitable it will be
and then you submit that as a completed
project and that's evaluated to uh
award you your completion certificate
for the course
and
this is a Purdue University course
Professor uh tornado mate is uh
the
the course
director he is the associate dean of
research and a professor of
communication at Purdue
and he's responsible for the oversight
of the curriculum the master classes
um
expert instructors from industry you saw
Bernadette Chambers
the
different individuals we can make
available their LinkedIn profile so you
can see what their background is but for
example Bernadette is an entrepreneur
who is the CEO of the socialite Hive
which is
her company that does social media
Consulting and marketing
so she's got a long experience of
working in the digital world in new and
disruptive ways and all the other
instructors here have similar experience
in Industry so we're talking about
people that do this as part of their
normal day-to-day job and have agreed to
to share that expertise and knowledge
with you through our classes so
you'll also encounter
people from industry who are brought in
to do the level up sessions as part of
this program so you'll meet people like
the chairman of idea uh if you uh you'll
meet
people like the chairman of JetBlue
Airways the uh
the United States Airline
um you'll meet other folks who are
consultants and of course Ms Horan who
is on the board of directors of Nokia
so these are leaders in in Industry uh
people who understand not only digital
technology but how digital technology
can disrupt
um an existing industry
um
JetBlue Airline Airways being a great
example of how to take an industry
that's been around since around the
1920s
commercial airlines and turned them into
something new with digital technology so
let's talk a little bit about learner
successes
um here are some testimonials and we'll
be able to review these I'll be sending
out a link to a recording of the session
um
and these are folks who have gone
through this transformation program
and uh
succeeded very well
um
you can see some of their comments about
their experience and and
their interactions with the instructors
so
very proud of that
we're also proud to to offer to Learners
specifically in the U.S and in India
um job assist Services career assist
only available unfortunately in those
two countries so if you're a learner
from another
part of the world take a look program of
course but you won't receive these
particular services but for those who
are in India and in the US we offer
services that include uh
particular services that extend six
months after you get your
certificate
um to help you find a new job if that's
your intention and your motivation for
the course
um
so if you are looking to to leverage
this to change careers or change
employers we provide support for that we
don't guarantee jobs but we do provide
you tools that will help you find
next job so categories are expert
webinars career events that we run for
free that are available to you on a
lifelong basis
um
but also that your portfolio that you
build within the program is a
important tool for
supporting your job search and
providing evidence
to potential employers to back up your
claims on your resume and in your
interviews
the job assist Services which are
offered through two firms Talent Inc and
IIM jobs Talent Inc in the United States
IAM jobs in India
and both of these are organizations
devoted to helping people
get ready and conduct their current job
search so
um you get access to job portals resume
rabbit in the US or IM jobs Pro in India
and you have six months membership to
that after your
certificate is issued
um does give you access to exclusive job
listings those are valuable parts of the
program I think they're not as valuable
as the other two parts because the
resume resume review and rewrite service
um taking on uh much more importance
the current world digital transformation
has hit Human Resources like every other
part of industry and so
you won't get your resume in front of a
human being unless it has gone through
an AI bot as part of an automated resume
tracker and
your resume has to pass the AI Bots
review that matches it against the job
description
understanding how to format your resume
in a way that is accessible and readable
by the AI bot and puts the information
in a form that it can easily match to
job descriptions
almost an art form but what raises it to
a true art form the fact that at the end
of that process your resume will go in
front of a human being will go either on
paper on a desk but more likely on the
screen and people have to look at that
and immediately recognize why it's
attractive why you're the right
candidate so having assistance in
rewriting your CV your resume to
appear
attractive to human beings while at the
same time be accessible to automated
systems is a really valuable part of
this service
as is the one-on-one interview service
and Career Mentoring which gives you
some direction in where to take your job
search but also gives you practice
sessions for both the technical
um
interviews about your new skill set
as well as
more soft skill type interviews that
have to do with whether you're a team
player how you fit into an
organization's culture and that type of
thing so being able to practice these
interviews and being prepared to put
your best foot forward in both types of
interviews again extremely valuable to
you
as I mentioned you have the expert
webinars may have to do with particular
technology areas particular
career Fields what the Outlook is for
the next uh
year coming ahead or what's currently
hot in the given industry you might take
a micro class in a particular skill
from one of our instructors
you might get
uh pardon me excuse me expert career
advice
um
for example see
the executive from indeed.com
who talks about how to navigate job
boards and get the best results so all
of these types of things are available
and you can take them every week for
free
let me start this next poll here
it's based on what you've heard and seen
so far today
are you interested
in taking this program
we'll leave this open for a short while
and I think the numbers are starting to
level out so please do get your answers
in if you're going to answer the poll
very close to three quarters of our
audience are interested in taking the
program so that's very encouraging and
it's also an opportune time for me to
share how to do that
so
enrollment steps are very
straightforward the process is simple
you email it email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net I will put that into the
chat so you'll have that at your
fingertips so you email to us contact
our learning Consultants they will tell
you what information you need to submit
for your application
we will review the application and
you'll receive an admission offer by
email from us
um
at which point
you'll join the program our next cohort
starts uh first February with a
orientation
your actual live virtual classes start
on 18 February
and it goes on for six months after that
you will need to attend live virtual
classes
in person for most of the sessions we'd
recognize that there may be something
that comes up where you might go on a
vacation or have some other obligation
on a weekend
um that will preclude you from attending
that week's classes but we do allow you
to access recordings of the classes on
occasion
that way you can both review what you
learned when you attended or you can
catch up on
uh class if you happen to miss it again
there is a requirement to attend a
large percentage of the classes in
person but you can't rely on doing this
program by just reviewing recordings
um that's why we encourage you to make a
commitment of at least the 10 hours a
week
um you can see the fee schedule here
the Indian fee is one lock forty seven
thousand five hundred rupee
um which you can Finance at 48.97 a
month
uh no no interest financing uh inclusive
of taxes uh in the U.S uh the and for
every other country outside the US
besides India that is four thousand two
hundred and seventy nine dollars
uh financing available at 377 a month so
contact us at ask us at simplyman.net
and we can get the process started for
you
so
real quick question for those of you who
said you are interested in
taking this program
how soon would you plan to enroll
one of those things where we say if this
is something that is going
to uh positively impact your life
your career it's probably worth doing
sooner than later
well that's a personal decision so I'm
going to let this run for another
uh 20 seconds or so
we still have a few coming in I think
it's
leveled off
so here is the poll result
and almost 40 percent of you said
that you are interested in starting
immediately in that February cohort or
maybe the one right afterward
another quarter of you said that you'd
want to do this
within six months
so if you're looking at doing it
immediately of course you want to email
us and ask us simplylearn.net get that
process started if you're looking at
doing it further out uh still email us
and ask us at simplyner.net we'll answer
any final questions you have and we'll
make sure that you have are kept
informed about future cohorts
so at this point we can go into the
questions and answers
and I will
stop sharing the screen because you
don't need to look at that slide look at
me instead
and uh it may not be an improvement but
I'll adjust for that
um
so what are the pro we've got a number
of questions I haven't been able to
track all of them but I'm going to take
as many as I can
um
I'm taking them from the Q a so if you
put a question into the chat would you
please um
copy it over into the Q a
the first one is from
brush test uh
Rush uh says what are the prospects for
someone from Healthcare or medical back
um and I can certainly address that
because my wife is a registered nurse
here in the United States
my wife started working on a medical
surgical floor at a major medical center
um where patient care is Hands-On and
everything had to be documented on paper
over the years they started introducing
Information Systems
that would help people document
electronically
and then they started introducing other
systems of the nature of
automated medical dispensing systems
where to reduce the incidence of
medication errors they would put
patients medications into an automated
Walker basically and you would have to
make sure that you were getting the
right medication for the right patient
in order to
administer it so
um now my wife works in the telephone
triage nurse at a call center
however she's not actually at the call
center
she works from home
and so transformation of her career
as a nurse
from providing bedside care and doing
everything on paper to providing virtual
care and doing everything based on the
information system illustrates
scope of digital transformation in
healthcare and it's just phenomenal
because not only has digital technology
affected
um the actual mechanics of health care
for everything from
automated blood pressure monitors to
computerized tomography
Imaging systems to um
automated or online medical records
electronic medical records
um to surgical robots all of that
technology is
transformed the actual practice
but also the flow of information and the
delivery of
a health
services in a system has radically
changed because of digital
transformation so if you are in health
care if you are in that domain
you understand digital transformation of
really great opportunities ahead for
helping organizations manage those
future transitions
uh
Daniel okay uh Daniel had a question
because we will uh I'll address that
offline and I'll send you an email
Daniel but um
uh
has an issue about enrolling in the
program he's
needs a little technical assistance for
that we'll be asking a question about
that actually
um
is this program the same as the
professional certificate program in
digital marketing uh and Assam this is
not the same program
it's offered by Purdue University and
that's the same uh
Bernadette is one of the lead
instructors in this program and also in
the digital marketing program that's the
same but digital marketing doesn't look
necessarily the the program in digital
marketing doesn't look necessarily at
the transformation of an organization or
business processes it assumes that you
are operating
uh were already in the process of
transitioning into digital marketing as
your mode of customer interaction
this program assumes that you have not
made that transition that you are
looking at the disruption of your
industry or of your business processes
or the opportunities opened by
technology and you learn how to
interpret those and
manage those and leverage those for uh
future benefits so very different
programs actually
um
if you're not in a management position
what sort of influence do you need to be
able to apply digital transformation
beyond that is a very good question
um as it happens
learning these skills maybe give you the
kind of influence that will help you
move into a management management
position because you'll be able to offer
advice
people in management about what is
possible and how to approach digital
transformation
um
you'll also understand
as your organization changes as your
industry changes you'll be mission to
see what opportunities are there and
bring those to the attention of
management so this is a good way to
Keen visibility in your organization be
more visible be regarded as a more
valuable person
um and
you do need influence but that's part of
the digital leadership module that talks
about how to exert that kind of
influence in different ways
depending on where you are in the
organization and what you're
position level is what your role is
um because it is possible
to manage processes from the bottom up
if you have the
knowledge and expertise and you can
demonstrate that you're the best person
to guide that
you can be delegated that responsibility
so
um
does the agile transformation module
provide pdus for pmps
I believe that is the case and you would
want to ask that question of our
learning consultants and also look at I
shared the link to our
program page
look at that
I believe the number of pdus is fairly
high so
um
will we send a recording I will send a
we'll be sending out a follow-up email
that has a link to this recording you'd
be able to review this
asks a question what is logistics
Logistics is the term for
the
provision of resources to an
organization
the logistics talks about
the supply chain for example Central uh
part of it where you need to supply
your organization with materials and
resources to make
whatever it is you produce and then have
to have a supply chain outbound that
delivers your products to the rest of
the world moves your products into the
supply chain of some other organization
so Logistics talks about that usually
when people speak about that they're
talking about things including things
like
physical Transportation warehousing
other types of things so Logistics is a
very important part of any
organization's operations unless it's
purely a service organization
um
of course content and see we've covered
the duration of the course is six months
and
is there a module or unit on change
management included in the course
curriculum
um yes that that's covered
in a couple of the elements of the
course
both in terms of the agile
transformation module
so that you understand
how to apply agile and scrum but also
um in the digital leadership of pretty
much all of digital transformation is a
change management
discipline so
change management techniques and tools
are baked into this
uh
digital marketing for digital
transmission
uh Sydney asked that the question you
know
I'm not sure where that expression came
from but
um my interpretation of that expression
if I was just reading it is
um
if you are delivering a service or a
product that is digital in nature
for example a streaming service or a
financial service or any other type of
service where the product is
delivered electronically delivered
digitally
um
you don't have the ability to put it
onto a store shelf
so you need to be able to contact
potential customers
uh through the the
digital medium
and conduct your transactions in that
way because that's the way they're going
to receive the product
so for example I have subscribed to the
newspaper the Wall Street Journal
or um
about
40 years now
and
I don't receive it in paper form anymore
it used to be delivered to my doorstep
um
now I receive it in digital form so I
access it when I want to from the
website
I get a lot of the information pushed to
me
through my email and that includes email
messaging about different products that
Wall Street Journal offers self and
through Partners so
um all of that interaction I have with
them is through a digital domain rather
than uh physical
paper-based domains
um
what is the career process roadmap
career progress roadmap for this course
I would
contact our learning consultants for
more information on that you can also
look at our
website which may have some information
about she
about salaries in future packages the
one difficulty in answering the question
is because digital transformation covers
such a broad range of different roles
uh
members every industry
it's really difficult to point to a
particular uh
role or differentiator and say this is
what the path is because
you can be moving up into General
management you could be moving up to
become a CTO or a c
m o or
you know any of the other c-suite levels
as your ultimate career goal and digital
transformation supports those so you
know you might take a look at some of
the resources like Glassdoor indeed to
see what happens when you uh
put in the search term digital
transformation and see what comes out of
that
um
dashara is an automation developer
works as an automation developer a team
lead pre-sales
um and
doesn't have knowledge of cloud or big
data or AIML
so do you still have to go through the
course to get better jobs well and
the answer of course is always that it's
possible to
gain these skills
from other resources there's a lot of
material that's available
books there's still exist there's a
YouTube videos there's a lot of other
materials that are available to get you
some Basics
um
the quality of your preparation and the
speed at which it happens what we're
offering in this course because we're
going to be working with industry
professionals who will be sharing their
knowledge and taking you through
exercises and guiding you through the
process so you won't feel like you're
lost and all on your own
you've got the the background that you
you have you can pick up a number of
different skills uh or general knowledge
about cloud and big data and AI so forth
um other ways uh
alternatively use this program
and within six months you would have a
foundation in all of those Technologies
plus the methodologies
um and business strategy behind digital
transformation so
um
this sounds like a great it would be a
ideal course for you
um
but again we never say that you there's
only one path to success
it depends on what works best for you
um
once we successfully complete the
program our two lasts
why would companies select you over
others of actual experience in digital
transformation what program what will
the program provide that the employer
should consider you so
um this is the reason why we structure
the program as we do order
to demonstrate
that you've gained the skills we run you
through case studies projects
um things of the nature that Bernadette
shared
where you have to implement and show the
result
um
the Capstone project is the ultimate
culmination of that process where you
have to show that you've mastered all of
the skills that have been covered in the
entire course entire program
and what you end up with are
examples that you can take in your
portfolio and show to potential
employers
of the work you've done so that
where people may be able to say okay
this is some actual experience that I've
had
um you'll be able to say the same thing
this is actual experience this is the
way I've addressed this problem this is
how I solved it
and if you hire me this is
the type of work that I can do for you
and how I'll solve these kinds of
challenges for you
um so this is a
good opportunity
to um gain
demonstrable experience that you show
that you far ahead of other people who
have just taken
academic training in this area
so you may not be able to compete at the
level of somebody who's done this
uh for a number of years but the level
of demand for this type of service
means that employers may not be able to
find
the people with
quote unquote actual experience that
you're
comparing yourself to so I wouldn't uh
wouldn't necessarily
be afraid of that competition
um
Shiva Kumar says I do not have a
background uh in the digital world of
marketing
um how can I share in it if I'm looking
for mid-career transition so this is
one of the paths this this uh program
actually is valuable because it's not a
programming course it's not a heavy
technology course you can come into it
um you need critical thinking skills
most of all
to understand how organizations work and
once you have that you have another set
of skills that allow you to work in the
digital domain
and work on digital transformation
projects
um without necessarily having to be
a
expert in
the Technologies themselves or or
digital marketing or that type of thing
you'll gain the
tools in the background that you in
order to be able to to make that
transition
um
and shiv Kumar also asked uh
can a non-it background person go into
this course or is there a programming
language that's mandatory there is no
programming language requirement
if you
are in this course you're probably not
going to be doing
programming per se you're going to be
using non
non-coding platforms that allow you to
build
use different tools to build prototypes
and uh
is very much like the analogy being that
if you want to start a website now you
can go the route of learning
um how to be a full stack developer and
then build your website or you can go to
a service that gives you the tools to
build your website with drag and drop
tools and that type of thing so you
don't need to know coding you just need
to know what it is you want your
your website to achieve and this is very
similar
this dashara asks discovers the basics
of cloud AIML and so forth you would you
have to go to further training to become
expert in those areas and then of course
you would have to go to further training
to become an expert in those areas
um the intention of this program is for
you to understand those areas
to the level where you can say
um we can use the cloud for this
function
this is how we would do it we can
ask an AI developer to pursue this type
of solution or we can
look to machine learning to help us
solve this problem you don't have to be
the one who understands how to build
that
or install it
but you'll have enough information
enough expertise to be able to say
this is possible this is something that
we can do or we can ask somebody to do
for us which
very valuable as opposed to somebody who
imagines that it must be possible
the old cliche if they can put a man on
the moon why can't they do this well
sometimes putting a man on the moon is
more straightforward
from the problems that you want to solve
other domains and there's
engineering and Technical disciplines
that made it possible
for
the
Nationals and Aeronautics and Space
Administration to be able to put
together
the systems the Rockets the vehicles
that took people to the Moon
you need the understanding of what's
possible but you don't need to be the
engineer that makes it happen
guesses Lead Me summary of that question
with that we've reached over time and
those are all the questions we had in
the Q a
I will now conclude the webinar with one
last question for you and the audience
this is the basic question are you
requiring assistance
get enrolled you have other questions
you'd like to have answered you want to
be taken through the process
the numbers stop changing so I'm going
to share the result and about a third of
folks have said that they're interested
in having assistance where you contact
us ask us simplylearn.net for that
and the rest of you are confident you
could
uh if you're going through a role you
can do it without further assistance so
that is great as well conclude the
webinar
I will put into the chat one last time
the information about email address and
a link to the program page which is also
what's in the QR code there you have
opening that and I'll give you a second
to get that out of the chat but I want
to thank everybody who joined us for
this webinar today and we really hope
that we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with Purdue
University and simplylearn
um
and we wish you a good evening good
morning a good day depending on where
you are thank you so much for being here
and that concludes the webinar